Washington is waiting tonight for
President Trump to release the
Democratic rebuttal to that Republican
memo alleging bias and the FBI and
Justice Department chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge is here
with all the developments good evening
Catherine well thank you Chris in the
last hour the White House deputy press
secretary releasing a statement that
this afternoon the president met with
the FBI director a senior Justice
Department official as well as the White
House counsel's office to get their
input quote the president is weighing
his options and will respond soon
earlier today in the Oval Office
President Trump was asked about the
Democrats counter memo and he promised
developments after Monday's unanimous
vote behind closed doors to make the
Democrats version public the president
had five days to voice objections under
long-standing congressional rules the
Democrats version drafted by the ranking
Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff his 10 pages long
more than twice the length of the
Republican memo released last Friday
multiple sources say the Democrats go in
depth on sources and methods that would
likely call for sections to be blacked
out or redacted among the president's
options asking Democrats to redraft the
memo removing national security
information taking the same course as
the Republican staff memo and
declassifying the Democrats version in
full or declassifying the Democrats
version with heavy redactions House
Intelligence Committee Republicans and
Democrats are in a holding pattern with
the senior congressional source telling
Fox they expect developments tonight
Chris Catherine thank you welcome